let's call it what it is sometimes you
gotta call
you know call things what they are how
many hours day do you
dedicate to memorizing opening lines i
don't like like really only memorizing
so usually i combine memorizing lines
with
sort of analyzing them so instead of
you know repeating endlessly i like to
study the position again and try to make
new moves
and when i go over my opening repairs
are
a lot really a lot
because it's very hard these days to
remember things so
not that's not why i do it i do it
because i enjoy it there is a
trap not really though i i do it because
i enjoy it
my tribe doesn't work but wait
should be eight would be sneaky but
queen a496 takes takes takes takes takes
97 takes takes takes takes takes sticks
takes stakes takes sticks
nothing's gonna castle
uh okay let's do this
we should be this horrible but i just
want a cheapo please
please give me a cheapo please please
give me a cheapo
oh thank you oh
sorry sorry sorry oh my god
yeah it happens my friend
it happens you fell you fell for the
wrong guy
number one piece up
and i'm swinging hennis have you any
tips on how to study end games without
it being boring
did you beal forget the end games man
let it go let it go man
look you don't need the end games you've
got a piece more here
who needs end games you just have an
extra piece can you convert
an endgame with an extra piece if yes
don't need to study endgame
just enjoy life by my chestable courses
they're all about openings they're a lot
of fun
openings tissue chests and games teach
you boredom
okay um
maybe i should have started a little
more end games because i'm currently
struggling winning a position with an
extra piece
it's really hard to win it's really hard
to win this one by the way
the guy also plays one insta speed
okay this one is nice now i have i have
a chance to redeem myself
rook f7 perhaps
doesn't agree with you pablanca is not
around
to prove his point
are you still off of social media anup
are you living under under a rock that
prevents you from accessing
social media because today alone i sent
out like eight tweets
i am i messed up i am um
you know why to a1 to b1 my friend you
have to go to b1
it was a horrible conver well it's it's
it is a horrible conversion i think i'm
just going to give up my bishop i
i hate the way i play this game i'm just
gonna give up my bishop simply
i cannot stand it anymore let me think
how to give up the bishop
for now let's go here horrible
conversion but it's kind of hard the
bishop is kind of
stupid okay
he's giving me he's giving me chances
i mean chances to do some nice things
i shouldn't play for cheapos i'm a peace
up
i have to man up just
i have to man up guys this is ridiculous
okay g man up you can convert this don't
play for cheapos
you can convert an extra piece
are you 100 greatest just players of all
time probably not
probably not
but i am still you know
actually pursuing my goals so maybe i'll
be
you know even higher at the end at the
end of this beautiful journey
so we'll see about that i'd rather be
you know who i am
than be the 99th
99th best chess player of all time who
has already finished his career that's
what i can tell you
okay shall we take or not let's not
let's uh postpone the
decisive moment
so much struggle guys the struggle is
real
now it's done
okay thank you that was a nightmare to
convert this thing across nightmare